curiosity findet organisches methan auf
dem mars eine gelähmte frau steuert mit
ihren gedanken einen roboter und die
nasa stellt ein konzept für eine
wolkenstadt foren für your city findet
organisches methan der mars rover
curiosity konnte mehrfach stark erhöhte
mengen an methan feststellen methangas
entsteht hier auf der erde fast
ausschließlich durch biologische
prozesse und es könnte damit ein hinweis
für vergangenes leben auf dem mars ein
in san francisco berichteten die
wissenschaftler des projektes das die
atmosphärische analyse des forschungs
roboters auf dem mars zehnmal höhere
mengen an methan festgestellt hat als
üblich die werte seien aber genauso
schnell wieder gesunken wie sie
angestiegen waren
die forscher gehen deshalb davon aus
dass sich curiosity in der nähe einer
kleinen methanquelle befindet gelähmte
frau steuert roboterarm nicht gedankt
jan schaumann ist 55 jahre alt und
gelähmt wegen einer neurodegenerativen
krankheit kann sie sich vom hals abwärts
nicht mehr bewegen
doch nun konnte sie in einem experiment
nur mit der kraft ihrer gedanken einen
roboterarm steuern wie man in einem
video sieht ist sie in der lage mit dem
arm verschiedenste gegenstände zu
greifen und an einer anderen stelle
abzulegen
sie konnte sogar eine tafel schokolade
essen all das funktioniert dank zweier
mikrochips die 2012 ihr gehirn
eingesetzt wurden dort an einem ganz
bestimmten punkt des linken motorischen
kortex können die beiden 4 mm dicken
chips 96 neuronale signale des gehirns
abfangen wenn scheuermann also daran
denkt ihre hand zu bewegen und sich ihre
rechte hand nicht bewegt weil sie nimmt
ist dann empfängt der mikrochip die
signale und leitet diese an einen
computer weiter nun berechnet der
computer mit extrem komplizierten
algorithmen wie jan die roboterhand
bewegen möchte und gibt das an den
roboter weiter
innovatives nasa konzept eine stadt in
den wolken eines fremden planeten wer
von euch jetzt am star wars und science
fiction denkt hat zwar recht aber
unmöglich ist es deswegen nicht ein team
der nase hat nun pläne vorgelegt um
genau diese idee umzusetzen eine stadt
in den wolken und zwar auf der venus
moment hört man ja ständig format
curiosity findet wasser und mögliche
hinweise auf leben
die nasa bereitet sich darauf vor die es
menschen zum mars zu schicken und man
denkt schon darüber nach wie man den
mars wohl bevölkern könnte
doch die venus ist unsere erde in vieler
hinsicht wesentlich ähnlicher als der
mars sie ist fast genauso groß wie die
erde hat eine ähnliche gravitation und
wird häufig als zwillings planet der
erde bezeichnet wenn da nicht die hoch
giftige atmosphäre und die temperaturen
von bis zu 465 grad celsius werden doch
das l die nasa nicht auf bei 5 venus
missionen stellt sich das team in ihrem
konzept vor
zuerst soll ein roboter genaue messung
der atmosphäre durchführen und
sichergehen dass die mission auch sicher
ist dann folgt eine 30 tage lange
bemannte mission bei der live stream in
der umlaufbahn der venus weitere tests
durchführt wenn auch diese mission
erfolgreich verläuft würde eine weitere
bemannte mission 30 tage lang in der
atmosphäre der venus verbringen und
beginnen dort eine art wollten stand
aufzubauen ähnlich wie ein zeppelin
sollen diese 130 meter langen
raumstation mit helium befüllt werden
ein weiteres team würde dann innerhalb
dieser schrieben häuser ein jahr
verbringen um die venus weiter zu
studieren und eine menge tests
durchzuführen 50 kilometer über der
oberfläche der venus ist die atmosphäre
also der atmosphärische prozent genauso
hoch wie ihr auf der erde und die
temperatur liegt im durchschnitt bei
angenehmen 75 grad celsius
vulkanausbrüche könnten die dinosaurier
getötet haben
seit jahrzehnten streiten sich
wissenschaftler darüber welche
naturkatastrophe für das aussterben der
dinosaurier verantwortlich ist ein
gewaltiger methoden anschlag der den
himmel verdunkelt hat ist bis jetzt die
bekannteste den theorien
eine neue studie verweist nun auf
gewaltige und langanhaltende
vulkanausbrüche über 750.000 jahrelang
schleuderten die vulkane des dekans raps
im heutigen indien aschestaub und
kohlenstoffdioxid in die atmosphäre und
veränderten so das klima dramatisch die
geowissenschaftler der princeton
university haben steins proben
analysiert und nun beweise dafür
gefunden dass die vulkanaktivitäten
250.000 jahre vor dem aussterben der
dinosaurier begonnen haben demnach
könnten sie durchaus einen einfluss auf
das massensterben der tiere gehabt daten
nach der theorie der wissenschaftler
sorgten die vulkanausbrüche ähnlich wie
bei der meteoriten theorie dafür dass
sich der himmel verdunkelt und die
sonneneinstrahlung vermindert
gleichzeitig soll aber das
kohlenstoffdioxid den treibhauseffekt
verstärkt haben außerdem ist es möglich
dass schwefelgase durch die vulkane
ausgespuckt wurden und so giftigen
sauren regen verursacht haben dies
könnte den dinosauriern und vielen
anderen tierarten der damaligen zeit
stark zugesetzt haben einen großen
meteoriten einschlag wollen die
wissenschaftler jedoch nicht
ausschließen
beide ereignisse sind wahrscheinlich
sehr wichtig so blair schöne leiter der
studie
wir können nicht sagen so sagt er ob der
untergang der dinosaurier ohne beide
faktoren geschehen oder nicht geschehen
wäre
das kepler weltraumteleskop funktioniert
wieder
es hat wohl niemand mehr damit gerechnet
nachdem die welt raumfahrtbehörde nasa
im august 2013 die mission keppler
eingestellt hatte findet das
weltraumteleskop jetzt wieder
erdähnliche planeten keppler ist ab märz
2009 im all und sucht nach planeten die
unserer erde ähneln
über 4000 dieser planeten wurden in den
letzten jahren bereits auf diese weise
gefunden
sie alle befinden sich in der richtigen
entfernung zu ihrer sonne so dass wasser
in flüssiger form vorhanden sein könnte
außerdem suchte keppler vor allem nach
gesteinsplaneten die in der größe der
erde oder kleiner sind
das weltraum teleskop beobachtet einen
festen ausschnitt des sternenhimmels im
sternbild schwan muss sich jedoch mit
seinem sogenannten reaktions rädern
stabilisieren und immer wieder leicht
neu positioniert
als 2012 das erste dieser rede ausfiel
war das kein großes problem ist
beeinflusste nur das feintuning doch als
dann im mai 2013 auch noch das zweite
der fünf reaktions räder probleme
vermeldete war klar dass kepler nicht
mehr voll funktionsfähig arbeiten konnte
ohne diese reaktions räder ist das
teleskop im weltall nutzlos 16 monate
kreis zu kapern und ohne aufgabe in der
umlaufbahn der erde bis die ingenieure
der nase auf eine geniale idee kam wie
das teleskop weiterhin betrieben werden
kann dazu musste es so gedreht werden
dass die sonne auf eine ganz bestimmte
stelle des teleskops scheint auf diese
weise wird die sonne zu einem der neuen
3 reaktions räder und hilft das teleskop
richtig auszurichten die lösung ist
nicht perfekt die nasa selber
vergleichen lage keplers mit einem
bleistift den mann auf seinem finger
balanciert doch das projekt läuft wieder
jetzt unter dem namen k 22 und seinen
ersten planeten hat keiko auch schon
gefunden 180 lichtjahre von unserer erde
entfernt kreis dieser erdähnliche planet
den gerade einmal neun statt 364 tage um
seine sonne der nasa dürfte es dort
allerdings zu heiß für leben seien wie
wir es kennen keppler 2 hat außerdem
neue aufgaben bekommen dadurch die neue
position einen anderen blickwinkel auf
den sternenhimmel hat er liefert uns von
nun an zusätzlich bilder von
sternenhaufen aktiven galaxien und super
norway um geheimnisse in unserem
universum geht es auch in diesem video
die zehn grössten rätsel des universums
dafür eben hier klicken
alle infos gibt es wie immer im block
und in der app dafür hier klicken
allerdings auch zu den einzelnen themen
gibt es wie immer in der video
beschreibung was meint ihr hat curiosity
auf den mars erste anzeichen für leben
gefunden diskutiert es wie immer mit in
den kommentaren und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt